if we legalize them what's going to
prevent us who's going to control
the manufacture
of these drugs and how dangerous they
are
because
the bigger the attic population
the more these drug
companies are going to make
these pharmaceutical companies are going
to create synthetic and very dangerous
drugs
to what
to make the attic population bigger
to drive bigger profits okay
the greatest mortality rate
of drug abuse right now
comes from legal drugs believe it or not
alcohol and tobacco
they are the biggest reasons or the they
cause the biggest deaths right now
of uh
of overdoses or
their abuse causes the the biggest
mortality rate in this country okay
legalization will result
in these big pharmaceutical companies
selling these drugs now it's the dea and
the fda's position
that they should regulate and control
the amount of drugs and the potency of
these drugs and if we don't have the dea
and the fda
controlling the manufacture
of these very dangerous drugs
our population is going to adipolis is
going to triple
the deaths are going to quadruple
and basically
legalizing drugs is not going to solve
anything
because
the
addicts okay and these drugs that
they're using
cause them to commit criminal
acts crim another crime that they might
not commit when they're sober under the
influence of this very important drugs
that are going to be produced
by these pharmaceutical companies or
driving to commit crimes so that's not
going to solve
the the the the arrest and crime
situation
as a matter of fact we're going to have
more problems and we're going to have to
put more people in prison than we're
doing right now hector which drugs
concerns you the most
very basically the opiates right now we
are in a uh opiate epidemic okay the
mortality rate right now is higher than
a ever been patrick
we are losing 70 000 people at an
average a year of opiate overdoses and
these are not the cartels
these are our pharmaceutical companies
in 1999 the dea and the fda relaxed
their reinforcement control of these
pharmaceutical companies
there was pressure by lobbyists
that were for this uh pharmaceutical
companies
through congress
they
basically caused the the the dea the the
the food and drug administration to
lessen
the reinforcement
and therefore since 1999 to the present
the relaxing of enforcement of the
production of these drugs has created
the drug epidemic that we have now
we are now experiencing the worst
drug epidemic in the history of of our
country
more so than heroin abuse more so than
meth abuse even more so than fentanyl
and as these
drug companies
are permitted they will create
very powerful and synthetic drugs and
they're going to push them and sell them
to our attic population
so
legalizing drugs to me is no answer so
but let's let's stay on that so
let's get specific so opioids are legal
though right i mean yeah
you know
some of them i can get legally from the
doctor can i jump in for a second
because i think this is really important
um there's two things i i don't
necessarily disagree with you about the
commercialization of
the potential for drugs and the
commercialization i mean we've seen it a
little bit already with cannabis right
but
here's the other issue that happened
that you know i think is really
critically important
is
what is driving the illicit poison drug
supply right now is not opioids it's the
introduction of illicit fentanyl that's
coming in because we cut off china
and then the mexican cartels have sent
it over so that's what's causing the
overdose death right now it's poly drug
overdose and it's the illicit fentanyl
because people don't have a safe supply
of drugs people don't know what's out in
the street and i'm going to blame the
dea a little bit and some of the drugs
are because i've written about this
extensively there was a point in time
during the obama administration
where they started to crack down on
alleged pill mill doctors and i'm not
saying that those aren't out there but
what that caused it was a huge market
disruption that we need to understand
very clearly and what it took it took
legitimate paying patients
out from getting safe supply prescribed
drugs into the alyssa market where they
were now spending 60 bucks a pop for an
oxycontin pill
who recognize you know what it's cheaper
to get heroin and so then they started
using heroin and then the illicit market
supply got poisoned with fentanyl and so
it is not opioids that are driving the
overdose death yes they contributed it
but that's not the case
well i tend to disagree with you there
because
most people that are hooked on opiates
start
buying
consuming drugs that are prescribed to
them medically what drives these people
to
the abuse of fentanyl
methamphetamines
all these other dangerous drugs heroin
is a fact that they become addicted the
doctors cut them off they don't
prescribe these drugs to them anymore
and they run
to the black market to the cartels to
get their drugs but because they got cut
off from a safe supply because the dea
started enforcing the law in a fashion
that drove legitimate paying patients
the research
my master's degree is actually in drug
policy it's not an it's not a masters in
business
all the empirical research in the last
few years shows very clearly that the
link between
how we constrict interdiction does not
work because we can strip drug supply on
one side and it just balloons in another
area what we do is we play
a trillion dollar game of whack-a-mole
with the drug supply
and it's not working and if we start
talking about fiscal issues and about
how are we going to really impact and
save people's lives we have to recognize
the failures of our current policy
we're not winning the war on drugs kiki
and i'm tired of losing police officers
including kiki camarina because he got
killed when i was a young police officer
i remember his death i remember it
is we need to stop sending our cops
into
areas
where
we know it's a failure
that you know that's i think the thing
that really concerns me is this lack of
of reflection by our by our government
guys that are willing to just throw the
cops out there to solve societal
problems that can't be solved
for criminalization if you enjoyed this
short clip give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel and if you want
to watch the whole thing click over here